[Music]
6 41 here on a wednesday morning and we
welcome now metro sheriff joe lombardo
for our weekly morning cup of joe's
segment sheriff lombardo good to see you
again this morning
good morning john good to see you so we
start with the tragic case that we've
been following for the better part of a
week
the search now and into now the death of
two-year-old amari nicholson
it's a horrible case obviously and i
know there's a lot of investigation
still to be done on this
but just maybe can we talk a little bit
about the challenges of an investigation
like this for detectives
to try and get some resolution
yeah first and foremost i want to send
out my condolences to the family
and and try to get some modicum of
understanding what they're going through
associated with this
is a tragic event and i appreciate you
asking the question john because
you know as you imagine we we're human
beings also and
when we're dealing with a situation like
this
it charges us emotionally and especially
when we can't get answers
and you know there's a the life of a
two-year-old
involved and i think the most important
aspect of this is for us to get
information in a timely manner
unfortunately we were informed late in
this process
with the missing of the child there was
some assumptions that the child may have
been
with another family member and then you
know we subsequently had to get
heavily engaged because when we realized
there were some problems with the uh
the statements that were being made and
it
required
and so nevada child seekers assisted us
in searching
uh you know we have our officers on a
major case protocol
which involves hundreds of officers in
involved in this case so
it was long drawn out and we were we
were acting on
you know just small bits of information
and eventually
um you know how with the case ended up
unfortunately
it is believed amari's lost his life
the unfortunate piece on this is it's
going to be a no-body prosecution at
this point because
we're still attempting to locate this
young
young man and where he may be the
suspect provided some information as to
the whereabouts of the
of the of the child but that proved to
be false
so we're continuing to move forward
we're asking the public's help
and if they have any information that
may help us locate this individual kid
such a complicated story such a
frustrating story such a tragic story
and there are so many resources for
people who are in danger who are in
trouble and
unfortunately they weren't used in this
case but we'll certainly keep an eye on
that sheriff
let's switch gears to another uh ongoing
situation here in the valley
it's also tragic a lot of deadly crashes
so far this year
and again a lot of hit and run crashes
what is metro doing to try and track
these drivers down and what should
drivers
who are involved in this which they
shouldn't be in the first place what
should they
do well
anytime you're involved in an accident
your first point is to
render aid if you're able to do that you
know or
you know call for medical services if
somebody's sustained injuries
and you are to remain at the scene and
and wait for the police to respond
if it's a non-injury accident and you
feel comfortable
in conversing with the other party and
you can exchange information
like your insurance and vehicle
registration and all the things that
you need to follow up on an accident
with your attorney and or insurance
companies
you can do that and go about your
business but
if you want the presence of a police
officer and a
crime not a crime report but an accident
report you
it's your duty to wait there for the
police officer to ride and they will
walk you through the process
now if there's injuries involved it's a
mandate that an accident a police
officer responds
and an accident report is done if you
leave the scene of the accident
the proverbial hit and run if there is
no injuries it's an
additional misdemeanor crime for the
fault of the accident and for leaving
if you leave and there are injuries it
rises to a felony
and that's a b level felony which is i
believe two to 20 years
if you are convicted as such so the
important piece on this
is you know you could be involved in a
misdemeanor accident but
elevate it to a felony because you panic
for
various reasons you may not have
insurance you may have warrants you may
be intoxicated
i guess there's a plethora of reasons
associated with that but there's no
excuse for those actions
especially if somebody's injured and
we've just seen so many of those uh
collisions recently uh let's also not
talk about you know what john
yeah sure let me just build off that
back to your original question
so we have a robust investigation
all those um i think it's important for
people to realize that
you know you do a hit and run you think
you're you're going to easily get away
with that and
what is most common is we get
information off your plate or
registration or video cameras
and the the success that we experience
here at lvmpd and locating the drivers
of the other vehicle is very high
so it's important for people to realize
that let's finally talk about the budget
sheriff
last year during the depths of the
pandemic metro had to make a lot of
budget cuts a lot of tough decisions
hiring freezes where do things stand now
as the valley starts to come out of the
pandemic
yeah you're right we did have to make
some significant cuts and
we had some hiring freezes both on the
policing side the corrections side and
the civilian ranks and we even
eliminated some programs
we anticipated the sales tax to be
dire which is a significant number
associated with our budget but
in with the federal stimulus it wasn't
as bad as we predicted
so with that knowledge and ability to
move forward
and to go back to our six academy a year
program we are increasing hiring
and trying to get back to where we were
previous to the covid pandemic
but that doesn't happen overnight it's
like turning a cruise ship per se
we uh it's going to take us around 10 to
12 months to get back to our original
numbers
that we experienced before um and
on that note we've got a few seconds
left here we're in the middle of
national police week where we recognize
the work of
the men and women in law enforcement is
it getting harder to
to retain and also just hire folks to
join the force right now
yeah it is um you know we had a we had
not a significant additional number of
people separate from the police
department during the pandemic or last
year on
sue's calendar year last year we
averaged right around 170 on the
policing side
on an annual basis we had additional 60
people uh
leave last year so and we are having
trouble recruiting now that could be a
combination of
uh people's perception of the police
george floyd post events and then you
know people were in fear of the cove
we were essential workers we had to go
to work on a
daily basis just like normal business
where other people
had the ability to remain at home and
sequester themselves from the pandemic
and we didn't have that luxury so there
was some fear associated with that
um now we're moving forward people are
getting inoculated and
and hopefully we can increase those
numbers as we
continue to go forward now we're still
dealing with the perception of the
police
as a as a whole and but here locally
i think our communities wholeheartedly
and hopefully that will be a problem
sheriff we thank you once again for
joining us this morning
if you at home have a question for
sheriff lombardo you can submit it on
eight newsnow dot com find out if a
question is answered every wednesday
sheriff thank you once again for joining
us this morning
6 40